está cada vez mais difícil se deslocar
pelas cidades pelas grandes cidades
eu vim de carro pra cá hoje com mais
duas pessoas no carro é e o
estacionamento estava lotado
imagino que muitos de vocês também
tenham feito as escolhas tenham vindo de
carro se deslocar de carro pela cidade é
uma prática comum e faz parte do nosso
cotidiano e da nossa vida é a mobilidade
de são paulo que é a nossa grande cidade
no brasil ela está extremamente caótica
e afetada por várias variáveis a gente
tem hoje por exemplo em são paulo todos
os dias
o uruguai se deslocando dentro do metrô
são quatro milhões de pessoas todos os
dias a gente tem também os carros
trafegando na cidade com em média uma
pessoa 1.4 pessoas taticamente como a
taxa de ocupação extremamente baixa
a gente tem a poluição da cidade de são
paulo é 90% da poluição é causada por
veículos sendo eles carros caminhões e
ônibus
então o ar que a gente respira dentro da
cidade é um a carregado por conta do uso
do transporte individual sobretudo
porque o carro é responsável por 73% da
poluição em grandes cidades em geral
além disso a gente tem o custo da
gasolina não só o custo é monetário mas
o custo ambiental cada vez mais alto
o combustível não renovável e fóssil e
que enfim acaba trazendo outros impactos
muito significativos na vida de todo
mundo
esse cenário de mobilidade ele é
caracterizado por uma escolha que a
gente fez lá atrás
o modelo de cidade que é construído no
brasil que foi construído principalmente
no começo do século 20 com a
popularização dos do carro com o
crescimento da indústria automobilística
ele é um modelo de cidade feito para os
carros e não para as pessoas
infelizmente essas escolhas foram feitas
pelas pessoas que estavam no poder
naquele momento as pessoas que podiam
tomar esse tipo de decisão muito
influenciadas é claro pelo poder
econômico pelo lobby da indústria
automotiva então a cidade
eram feitas com vias para os carros e
com pouca calçada é cada vez mais a
gente tem por exemplo a gente tem um
problema sério de trânsito na mobilidade
travada na cidade em são paulo e aí há
alguns anos atrás decidiu se duplicar
marginal tietê criar outras vias na
marginal e o que aconteceu logo em
seguida foi que a gente continua travado
existem inúmeros estudos que mostram que
criar mais vias para os carros só faz
com que o problema piore
mas a nossa escolha desde o modelo de
cidade até hoje continua sendo essa
claro que tem mudado mas ainda assim é
um problema crítico e que atinge todos
nós todos nós todos os dias
esse modelo de cidade ele ainda é
refletido também nas nossas escolhas
pensando socialmente e culturalmente
sobre onde está o carro no imaginário
das pessoas o que o carro como o carro é
mostrado nas propagandas como cá revista
nas novelas o que símbolo é esse né que
transforma as nossas vontades e faz com
que a gente queira efetivamente comprar
um carro
hoje o carro ainda infelizmente é
sinônimo de status
a gente é promovido na empresa no
trabalho a gente consegue um primeiro
emprego ea gente entrar num
financiamento de vários anos para
comprar um carro viabilizar o nosso
deslocamento é claro que a gente está
com o transporte público saturado então
essa não é simplesmente uma escolha é
usar o carro comprar o carro não é
simplesmente uma escolha associadas a
status e associada à à altura e ao
ambiente que a gente vive mas também a
gente tem uma uma deficiência importante
de transporte público que faz com que
também a gente tem que escolher o carro
é esse modelo de cidade caótico vocês
todos sofrem isso no dia a dia né assim
como eu
eu comecei a perceber mais isso de uma
forma mais intensa e mais presente na
minha vida em 2013 em julho de 2013
eu tinha acabado de voltar de uma viagem
que foi a expedição 4 por um foi uma
viagem que eu fiz com mais quatro
pessoas quatro amigos meus de carro a
gente saiu de são paulo foi até o alasca
dirigindo desceu até o soar chaia
extremos
da argentina e voltou para são paulo
foram 13 meses de viagem um ano e um mês
a gente percorreu 72 mil quilômetros e
passou por 19 países
essa viagem foi uma das experiências
mais transformadores que eu tive na
minha vida é é claro que a gente viveu
ali um compartilhamento na veia a gente
viveu economia compartilhada como ela
deve ser em todos os aspectos da nossa
vida eram cinco pessoas jovens de 25 a
30 anos dentro do mesmo carro todos
homens é compartilhando tudo então a
nossa casa era o carro a gente tinha
cada um tinha um espaço dessa
profundidade mais ou menos um braço
dessa largo para colocar as nossas
coisas pessoais então tudo que a gente
tinha de roupa tudo que a gente tinha de
utensílios em enfim pessoais tava
naquele espaço então é só a gente dormir
inclusive em cima do carro a gente tinha
duas barracas automotivas barras de teto
que a gente abre quando o carro está
parado então a vida girou em torno desse
carro durante três meses durante por 19
países
e aí isso fez a gente experimentar o
compartilhamento em todas as formas e aí
a gente pensa é porque viagem incrível
que coisa maravilhosa que oportunidade e
com certeza que privilégio que eu tive
de passar a fazer parte disso
entretanto quando a gente olhava pra
isso logo no primeiro mês assim da
viagem
a gente viveu uma grande lua de mel na
era tudo maravilhoso era o que a gente
queria fazer era viagem dos sonhos de
todo mundo e aí o compartilhamento é
muito difícil
por mais que a gente não fala sobre isso
existem inúmeras questões que a gente
passa conflitos situações do cotidiano
do dia a dia quando a gente está num
ambiente de compartilhamento profundo
que são dificílimas ea gente não queria
olhar pra isso porque imagina a gente
está vivendo o sonho das nossas vidas e
era até difícil reconhecer esse
vulnerabilizar e dizer não a gente tem
um problema então em vários momentos a
gente foi relevando principalmente no
começo nos dois primeiros meses da
viagem
a gente estava tomado por esse espírito
de euforia e de lua de mel e tal e
agente relevou muitos dos problemas e
deixou de resolver os conflitos dos
até que chegou um momento que foi um
episódio muito curioso inclusive a gente
estava indo dormir a gente estava nos
estados unidos e uma pessoa alguém falar
que a gente vai acordar amanhã 1
respondeu 8 outro respondeu nove e aí
essa foi uma grande briga que a gente
teve a maior briga que a gente teve na
viagem todo
não porque o horário era diferente pra
mim e pra outros mas porque a gente
tinha acumulado uma série de conflitos
que não tinham sido resolvidos e que não
tinham sido falados e naquele momento a
bomba explodiu
e aí obviamente a gente não foi dormir
cedo a gente foi dormir às 5 horas da
manhã
a gente escolheu falar sobretudo gente
escolheu resolver os problemas de gente
escolheu aprender a cd ea gente entendeu
que a gente não fizesse isso
compartilhamento não ia fazer sentido a
viagem não ia durar a gente conhece
suportar a gente estava vivendo um
ambiente de tensão extrema ea gente não
tava curtindo a viagem tinha sido um
problema a gente tinha criado um
problema que a gente nunca imaginou que
a final
imagina a viagem dos nossos sonhos e que
todo mundo achava também era isso que
era viagem de emoções e aí nesse dia a
gente chorou todo mundo chorou pra
caramba roupa suja ea gente foi dormir
45 horas da manhã em um acordo nem as 8
e as noves não era o problema
definitivamente
e aí a partir daquele momento a gente
percebeu que o a gente aprendia com as
dificuldades com os conflitos cotidianos
e resolvia na hora e deixava de acumular
e sedia e entende o outro e criar uma
relação de empatia e respeitar o espaço
individualidade
apesar de quase não existe
individualidade nesse ambiente ou isso
não ia acontecer isso foi um grande
aprendizado que eu tive de
compartilhamento nessa época em 2012 e
2013 e aí de repente eu voltei para são
paulo que a viagem acabou ela foi assim
maravilhosa foi uma das experiências
mais transformadora da minha vida mas
ela acabou aí voltei para são paulo eu e
os quatro não voltamos todos pra são
paulo estamos melhores amigos somos
melhores amigos até hoje é e aí eu fui
jogado de volta nessa realidade
falando de mobilidade nessa realidade em
que eu olhava pra rua olhava em volta de
cada carro tinha uma pessoa dentro ea
gente
tinha passado um ano e um mês dentro de
um carro com ocupação máxima eram cinco
pessoas o tempo todo às vezes mais né
pessoas a gente acabou dando uma carona
e tal
enfim é e aí começou a me incomodar
profundamente eu comecei a perceber que
a gente naturaliza a taxa de ocupação
dos carros como se ela fosse aceitável
como se o carro tivesse sido feito para
uma pessoa mas na verdade ele foi feito
para 5 são é de uma duas toneladas que a
gente tem e hoje a gente usa essas duas
toneladas quase transportando 70 a 100
quilos
não faz sentido nenhum e aí por eu ter
vivido essa experiência importante e
transformadora de compartilhamento
eu comecei a negar comecei a não usar o
carro nunca tive carro mas na família
tinha eu usava de vez em quando eu falei
'não vamos deslocar de bicicleta faz
muito mais sentido era uma escolha
possível pra mim dentro do meu contexto
social onde eu vivia e tal e aí
começaram as ciclovias também
timidamente mas já fazia bastante
sentido comecei a me deslocar de
bicicleta e perceber que a mobilidade
ativa era um caminho possível na minha
realidade
e aí que vem então é o brinde que é hoje
uma empresa que empreendam há mais de
três anos que há uma solução de caronas
corporativas o que a gente faz é
promover essa solução de tecnologia de
carona para que as pessoas possam
compartilhar os trajetos dentro de redes
seguras
então a partir desse questionamento a
partir dessa percepção entendendo que
não fazia sentido que os carros
trafegarem com três a quatro assentos
disponíveis na cidade
a gente criou o blind pra efetivamente
resolver esse problema ajudar a resolver
hoje já são mais de 30 mil pessoas pelo
brasil que tem a oportunidade de
escolher através da tecnologia pegar a
oferecer carona a gente gera hoje 2000
caronas por mês mais ou menos o que é um
impacto pequeno mas pensando que é o
começo é bastante significativo e aí a
gente entende é que o compartilhamento
como eu falei ele tem muita dificuldade
portanto engajamento quando a gente fala
de carona no brasil é muito baixo quando
a gente tem a oportunidade é como eu
tive na expedição de ficar horas dia
meses com uma mesma pessoa com algumas
pessoas num círculo pequeno
compartilhando tudo né vivendo
intensamente aquele compartilhamento é
claro que quando a gente fala da carona
esse universo é bastante menor em termos
de escala mas essa é sim uma dificuldade
a gente vive uma sociedade extremamente
individualizada a gente resolve os
nossos problemas é de forma individual a
gente compartilha pouco a gente se
vulnerabiliza quase nada a gente não
mostra as nossas dificuldades
então a gente percebe que o engajamento
para carona precisa passar pela
desconstrução desse problema também né
pra compartilhar uma carona preciso
estar disposto a compartilhar um momento
você está disposto a compartilhar o meu
trajecto é então essa é uma grande luta
pensando em construir esse modelo
incentivar a cultura da carona e
sobretudo criar a cultura da carona do
compartilhamento no brasil a gente tem
feito isso porque a gente acredita que o
carro-bomba carro cheio não faz sentido
um carro se deslocar o carro pra gente é
o novo cigarro né então se acredita que
no futuro a gente vai ter movimentos e
claro com outras tecnologias carrollton
autónomas movimento de uso mais
eficiente do carro
até porque a gente usa o carro por
exemplo todo mundo que veio de carro pra
cá veio da sua casa ou de algum outro
lugar
estacionou aqui e o carro está lá parado
em média estatisticamente 95% do tempo o
carro está parado
a gente saiu de carro de casa vai para o
trabalho está só no carro um trabalho
trabalho 8 10 horas
volta pra casa dorme e pega o carro no
dia seguinte então o uso dele quando a
gente compara por exemplo com o avião é
um carro com uma pessoa sendo usado 5%
do tempo é uma pessoa dentro do carro
significa de 20 a 25 por cento da
capacidade ocupada né do carro
um avião com 20% a 25% dos assentos
ocupados é com certeza um vôo cancelado
e o avião nunca fica parado ele
desembarque os passageiros embarcam
outros passageiros então essa
ineficiência mudar o que é é dentro do
uso do carro que pra gente é muito
natural né a gente não encara isso com
indignação ela tem que mudar a gente tem
que perceber
não faz sentido mas usar o carro da
forma como a gente usa e aí é claro que
estou falando de escolhas e eu tô
falando de escolhas contextualizadas na
então não é pra todo mundo quer ou no
carro também não é pra todo mundo claro
é uma pessoa por exemplo que mora é na
cidade tiradentes zona leste de são
paulo trabalham no morumbi numa casa
demora duas horas e meia para chegar no
trabalho de transporte público demora
duas horas e meia para voltar
chega em casa ainda tem que cuidar da
casa vive no ambiente eventualmente
hostil tal essa pessoa não tem as mesmas
escolhas que eu tenho mas eu estou
falando aqui das escolhas que a gente
pode ter dentro dos nossos contextos no
meu contexto eu posso escolher a carona
eu posso escolher a mobilidade ativa e
acredito que muitos de vocês também
possam porque a gente faz parte de uma
de uma classe social muito parecida
além disso outras escolhas são sempre
possíveis é quando a gente fala de mudar
de desse futuro que está próximo
cada vez mais próximo a gente está
falando também de tudo o que a gente faz
no dia a dia e como essas coisas são
transformadores então por exemplo em
casa a gente escolhe
eu e minha companheira que está aqui
inclusive é a gente escolhe fazer as
tarefas domésticas essa é uma escolha
possível dentro do nosso contexto é não
contratar ninguém para limpar nossa
privada ea gente mesmo fazer isso
a gente escolhe fazer o nosso pão a
gente escolhe fazer o nosso eu curti a
gente escolhe compostar o resíduo
orgânico a gente escolhe se deslocar com
uma mobilidade eficiente e essas
escolhas constroem o futuro que a gente
quer
não esse futuro caótico está anunciado
que a gente acha que o mundo vai acabar
e que o apocalipse está para acontecer
mas um futuro que é possível dentro das
escolhas individuais e dentro do nosso
círculo de poder porque aqui a gente tem
diversos perfis de pessoas a gente tem
eventualmente pessoas que são
responsáveis pelo rh de uma empresa e
que podem escolher contratar a pessoa já
localizar é o de uma forma já localizado
então eu tenho dois candidatos
concorrendo por uma vaga que tem um
perfil mais ou menos similar mas uma
hora do lado do trabalho outro mora na
zona leste há três horas de transporte
público porque eu vou escolher e
contratar pessoas da zona leste por que
eu possa impactar
o ambiente daquela pessoa qualidade de
vida daquela pessoa e o ambiente do
trabalho escolhendo contratar de forma
já é perto pessoas que moram perto um
gestor público por exemplo ontem foi
anunciado o plano cicloviário novo da
cidade de são paulo pela prefeitura esse
plano cicloviário todas as entidades é
de mobilidade ativa questionário e
criticaram porque não foram consultados
então ninguém participou desse processo
mas o gestor público escolheu colocar um
plano ciclovia cicloviário de cima para
baixo então a todo momento nós que
estamos aqui assumimos papéis diferentes
e fazemos escolhas e essas escolhas são
importantes para que a gente tenha uma
cidade melhor para que a gente tem uma
mobilidade melhor para que a gente viva
cada vez mais compartilhando em harmonia
e sabendo que no futuro vai ser possível
ter uma vida melhor
muito obrigado